hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Rob camp ease
the president co-founder the Marijuana
Policy Project Rob thanks for talking to
us a huge huge year for MPP for
marijuana for freedom for chipping away
at the drug war why did legalization
succeed in Colorado and Washington State
and what does that tell us about the
kind of nations aight Geist about
marijuana use in both Washington and
Colorado the polling you know two years
ago was at about 50 50 and so we knew
that if we ran good campaigns in both
states that the number would probably go
up and not down we also knew that it was
highly likely that we were going to have
an advertising advantage because the bad
guys almost never have any real budget
to pay for their own ads we were
religious about like sticking with the
message that what we're doing is not
working and it's time for a new approach
that police have better things to do
with their time than the sniff under
people's doors for marijuana and the
third is that by taxing and regulating
marijuana that it would actually be
better for the taxpayers and spending a
lot of money on run incarcerated and
there was a lot of linkage to treat it
like alcohol treated like beer wine and
alcohol which also normalizes it and you
know this is a huge I mean this is like
pulling a thread out of everyday life
that touches education it touches law
enforcement certainly a diction count I
mean this is it going to be hard to
actually get these laws up and running
now it'll be easy to get them up and
running because what we did is we gave
ourselves about a year for both states
to implement imagine it in two parts the
first part which is happening right now
is that personal use and personal
possession is legal in the short term in
Colorado but not Washington adults can
grow six plants without any license or
any government intervention so that's
easy and then one year from now there'll
be licenses for businesses either
growing or or testing or selling
marijuana and that that might be the
area where it's a little tricky but I'm
I'm not even not concerned about it
quite frankly because we've already seen
state governments issuing similar
licenses for medical marijuana
businesses and certainly in Colorado has
a thriving medical marijuana business
which I guess is one of the reasons why
people were comfortable with it we're
getting passive aggression from the feds
certainly Department of Transportation
Drug Enforcement Administration the drug
czars office they've all stated that
federal law is still the law the land
and this stuff you're in trouble if
you're monkeying around with this
president obama and and Eric Holder have
been silent on the issue what's your
sensor is the federal government going
to like fight this to the end the Obama
administration is going to be slightly
hostile but not terribly postle so on
the criminal side the federal government
does not have the resources to go after
any individuals caregivers businesses
etc in either state Washington State's
ballot initiative was somewhat
controversial among legalization
proponents in that it did specify
penalties for driving under the
influence of marijuana what is the way
that that's going to work out in terms
of being tested is there a sense of how
how will police know if somebody is high
while driving in Washington State it's
going to be similar to how it works with
alcohol in any state which is that the
cops aren't going to just start randomly
stopping drivers and taking their urine
or taking their blood to look for
alcohol or marijuana that you actually
have to be driving what the police would
say we'd be dangerously and then after
some field sobriety tests you know
touching your nose and walking the line
and so forth then after the police feel
like maybe you really are dangerous then
they could take you in for the for the
blood test you know did you ever really
seriously think that you would be seeing
states legalizing marijuana use by
ballot initiative in your lifetime yes
oh yeah I absolutely did are we behind
or ahead of yours well unfortunately the
American people are a little bit behind
Rob campuses scheduled by that but
things are on track yeah what did you do
to celebrate the legalization of
marijuana in Colorado and Washington so
I was actually in denver on election
night because we had a feeling that we
were going to win there and that was the
initiative that we were more financially
invested in and so my goal was to be
absolutely sober for all the interviews
i had to do
and then afterwards drinking a bit of
whiskey so that's my my personal
contribution to election night but I
have to tell you that it was a wonderful
feeling being in that that celebration
with people in Colorado who actually
lived there full time I only lived there
part time and just to see everyone just
going wild on on election night where
people didn't even really care about any
of the other elections it was the most
important election night celebration
I've had well that's great we'll leave
it there Rob Campea of marijuana policy
project thanks for the work that you've
done and congratulations on the success
of this for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie